>>> JUST MOMENTS AGO, GEORGIA'S
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR SIGNED A
SWEEPING ELECTION OVERHAUL BILL
IMPOSING NEW RESTRICTIONS ON
VOTE THING THE STATE.
JOINING US IN "THE SITUATION
ROOM," MARTIN LUTHER KING, III.
THANK YOU NOR COMING ON.
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
REACTION ABOUT THIS BILL THE
GOVERNOR JUST SIGNED INTO LAW.
IT'S ONE OF MANY EFFORTS UNDER
WAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
RESTRICT VOTER ACCESS.
WHAT IMPACT WILL THIS LAW HAVE
ON VOTERS IN YOUR STATE OF
GEORGIA?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S A
VERY SAD DAY FOR THIS STATE.
IT BODES TO MOVING BACK TO JIM
CROW ERA KIND OF LEGISLATION.
THE IMPACT CERTAINLY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE VOTERS,
PARTICULARLY OF COLOR, WHO
NORMALLY WOULD HAVE -- ALL
VOTERS WOULD HAVE A LONGER TIME
TO VOTE.
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING IN
THAT LEGISLATION THAT SAYS YOU
CAN'T EVEN BRING SOMEBODY WATER.
HOW INHUMANE CAN THESE
LEGISLATORS BE?
EVEN THOUGH THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T
VOTE, HE APPROVED IT BY SIGNING
THE LEGISLATION.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING, IT'S
GREATLY DISAPPOINTING THAT OUR
STATE HAS GONE IN THIS
DIRECTION.
WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE MORE
VIGILANT, BLACK PEOPLE, YOUNG
PEOPLE, OLDER PEOPLE, POOR
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE FOR
MORE VIGILANT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THIS TREND IS
HAPPENING ACROSS AMERICA AND
OVER 40 STATES ACROSS OUR
NATION.
IT USED TO BE A TIME IF YOU
CALLED SOMEONE A RACIST, THEY
WOULD WANT TO RETREAT.
NOW IT SEEMS TO BE ALL RIGHT TO
BE A RACIST.
IT'S A SAD DAY IN AMERICA, QUITE
FRANKLY.
>> AND YOU VIEW THAT BILL THAT
HE SIGNED AS A FORM OF RACISM.
>> EXCUSE ME?
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU
VIEW THE BILL HE SIGNED AS A
FORM OF RACISM?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S NO OTHER REASON WHY
WOULD YOU PUT SOMETHING IN
PLACE -- YOU SAID WE HAD A GREAT
ELECTION BACK IN JANUARY, ON
JANUARY 5th.
OF COURSE, LAST YEAR IN
NOVEMBER.
THERE WERE NO FLAWS OR ANYTHING.
WHY WOULD YOU RESTRICT?
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE EXPANDING
THE RIGHT TO VOTE TO MAKE IT
EASIER, NOT RESTRICTING THE
RIGHT TO VOTE.
IT'S A TRAVESTY, TRAGIC.
AND I THINK VOTERS, MAYBE THIS
IS GOING TO BACKFIRE.
THE HOPE IS THAT MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE WILL VOTE, BECAUSE THEY
MADE IT SO MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
BY WHAT THEY HAVE DONE, WHICH
SHOULD BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WE LEAD THE NATION AND THE WORLD
IN PROMOTING DEMOCRACY, BUT WE
ARE BLOCKING DEMOCRACY AT HOME.
IT'S A SAD DAY IN GEORGIA AND A
SAD DAY FOR AMERICA.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON WHAT WE HEARD FROM JOE BIDEN
TODAY.
HE SAID HE AGREES WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT THE FILL
BUSTER IS A RELIC OF THE JIM
CROW ERA.
YOU WROTE ABOUT THE PHIL BUSTER
IN A NEW OP-ED FOR CNN CALLED
"THIS IS WHAT MY FATHER WOULD
HAVE DONE."
WHAT WOULD YOUR FATHER HAVE DONE
ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, NUMBER ONE, PERHAPS IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ADDITIONAL
MOBILIZATION EFFORTS BEFORE IT
GOT TO THIS PARTICULAR POINT.
IN FACT, I WOULD SAY IF MY
FATHER HAD LIVED, WE WOULD BE
DEALING WITH DIFFERENT ISSUES,
NOT ISSUES WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT NOW, THE ONLY THING WE CAN
DO IS MOBILIZE AND ORGANIZE AND
TO GET MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
REGISTERED.
WHEN THE VOTING STARTS, TO VOTE
IMMEDIATELY.
THOSE ARE THE ONLY PROVISIONS
I'M AWARE OF.
THE FINAL PROVISION MAY BE IF
THE SENATE PASSES, YOU KNOW,
S-1, WHICH IS BEING TALKED ABOUT
AND SENATOR SCHUMER AND SENATOR
KLOBUCHAR AND MANY OTHERS ARE ON
BOARD TO DO THAT.
IF THAT HAPPENS, SOME OF THAT
WILL BE ADDRESSED.
AND THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS
ACT.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO WHAT CINDY HIDE SMITH SAID
ABOUT VOTING ON SUNDAY,
BASICALLY SAYING YOU VOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO VOTE ON SUNDAY BECAUSE
THAT'S THE DAY TO PRAISE GOD.
>> EVERYBODY HAS THEIR OPINION
IS WHAT I WOULD SAY.
I THINK THAT IN THE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR, AND MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES, AFTER CHURCH, SOULS
TO THE POLLS.
MANY ARE LED TO THE POLLS.
CERTAINLY WE CAN PRAISE GOD ALL
THE TIME, AND GO TO CHURCH ON
SABBATH DA